another too weird for prime time show
was Fox's get a life a surreal comedy
starring and co-created by Chris Elliott
Elliot plays Manchild Chris Peterson who
at 30 still lives at home still has the
same paper route he had as a kid and
still doesn't have a driver's license
while that might seem like the premise
for a fairly standard sitcom g a life
was anything but with episodes about
everything from finding a vomiting alien
which Chris barbecues and eats later in
the episode to Chris inexplicably
discovering he can see a few seconds
into the future
oh and Chris is also killed in 12 of the
show's 35 episodes that tastes
weird uh-oh wrong
bottle ratings were never great for the
show but get a life was actually given a
second season it's easy to see in
hindsight how ahead of its time the show
was plus how influential it would be for
the blossoming alt comedy movement on TV
and it's a blast to watch today with
that perspective